hi there today we're looking at movement
pruning adaptive sparsity by fine tuning
by Victor Sun Thomas Wolfe and Alexander
M rush of hugging face and Cornell
University on a high level
this paper proposes that you should if
you have a transfer learning objective
and you want to do pruning you should
not do pruning by weight magnitude you
should do pruning by how much the
weights move during the transfer
learning this yields better result in
the very sparse model regimes and is
specifically relevant to current NLP
transfer learning tasks such as BIRT
models so if you like content like this
consider subscribing and sharing it to
your friends and as always leave a
comment if you have anything to say on
this alright let's dive in so they say
magnitude pruning is a widely used
strategy for reducing model size in pure
supervised learning so what is magnitude
pruning now if I have a neural network
let's say I have a convolutional neural
network and I input my little cat right
here and I have a bunch of layers right
and now if we look at these layers each
of these layers is going to be made up
of these units of the neurons and the
next layer is also made up of these
neurons now what kind of neural network
that is is not that important but what
is important is that you have these
connections from neuron to neuron and in
let's say a fully connected Network
every neuron is connected to every other
neuron in a CNN that will be slightly
different but in essence you have a lot
of connections here and these are
usually called weights so these are the
weights now the problem is if I train
like this giant neural networks and I
want to ship them for example to mobile
devices to my customers then there they
won't be able to download gigabytes of
models or even like hundreds of
megabytes of models just not possible so
what we're going to do is we want to
prove
this model which means we want to remove
parts of these baits a lot of these
weights but we won't we don't want to
lose accuracy of the network so imagine
I have a network and that's trained its
LAN image classifier is here it's cats
or dogs and I have it trained to a good
accuracy I want to delete these weights
but I want to retain the performance and
these methods are called pruning now
what people do is usually they sort of
go in a stepwise fashion they say well
first of all I don't need some of these
and then they delete some and then they
sort of retrain the pruning Network and
after that they go again and they say
well I don't really need that one and
they don't really need that one so they
do it in this stepwise fashion until the
network is of the size that they want
and the hope is that you don't lose too
much accuracy so the current the
question is how do you select which
weights you need and which ones you
don't need and usually this is done by
so-called magnitude pruning which means
that look at the way you look at the
weights and the weights they'll have
some distribution there will be terribly
very negative so here is very negative
weights and here is very large positive
weights and what you'll say is that okay
probably the weights that are very large
they contribute a lot to the signal of
the network within the network and the
weights that are quite small there you
know since there's all this noise and
stuff they're probably not that
important so I'm going to cut off
basically right here and everything
that's in here I'm going to delete those
are the non important weights whereas on
the outside those are the important ways
this is called magnitude pruning because
it goes by the magnitude of the weight
the absolute value of the weight so you
don't actually need so there's not one
threshold here you don't need a
threshold you simply need a method to
order the weights right and then you
keep removing them until you're
satisfied with the size so this is
magnitude pruning now what's the
problem with the magnitude pruning in
these kinds of tasks they say however it
is less effective in the transfer
learning regime that has become standard
for a state-of-the-art natural language
processing applications so what do you
do in these transfer learning regimes in
the transfer learning regime and exit
let's go with the the image example
right here even though it's mostly used
in NLP we can do the same thing so let's
say we have a classifier here for cats
and dogs our classifier and we had a big
big database of cats and dogs images
right so we were able to train that
fairly well and we don't prune it yet we
have this full network now we want to
adapt this to a task where we want to
recognize whether or not the animal is
is sick so we develop this app for a
veterinarian and it's like a short
screening for a particular disease that
a cat might have and we already have
this cats and dogs classifier so it's
reasonable to assume that this
classifier has some good features to to
work with cats and dog images so what we
can do instead of because let's assume
for this other task we just have this
tiny little data set which is not enough
to train a neural network of this size
right but so in a first step we'll train
this big neural network on the cats
versus dogs and then we what we do is we
transfer learning so we transfer all the
weights right here and here we have a
different task now sick or not sick
right this is cat
this is dog and here is sick or not sick
not and of course we can't transfer
these particular weights but we hope
that the features here will sort of be
the same so we transfer them and then we
train these weights including the the
head right here this part we train it on
this little data set and we hope that we
already have this good starting point we
only need to you know learn the
basically the specifics of what makes
these two data sets different and we
won't have to learn entire task of
dealing with
cat-and-dog images from the get-go okay
so this is called transfer learning now
in this case we combine the two so first
we want to transfer learn like if we
build this app for that and then we
might say oh this is not you know this
is not only for vets this is actually
for anyone you you know who has a cat or
a dog at home so what we could do is
build an app where anyone at home could
stand there their cat and it would
output like a probability of the cat
having that disease so we want this
neural network is still the same size as
this neural network so now we want to do
the pruning we want this neural network
to become sparse to only have a couple
of connections left such that it's a few
kilobytes large but retain performance
now they say when you do this step you
can't just do the magnitude pruning like
you did right here and why not because
this is not this model right here is not
the result of a training step like of a
regular training process but is the
result of a transfer learning process
where first you do the big training and
then second you adapt it and why is that
the case
well ultimately what you want to do is
you want to prove the non important
weights now there could be a weight
right here this one that is very
important for the cat vs. dog task but
that is not important for the sake
purses nonstick tasks and we also we
know that in these transfer learning
settings the weights they don't tend to
move that much in general the research
shows that once you've trained a neural
network basically the beginning is
important but then once you did it like
if you adapt it or transfer a learn it
and so on the weights they won't move
that much so in in essence this weight
maybe starts out right here and it will
sort of stay around this place it will
maybe go a little bit down because it's
not important but it
move much during transfer learning
that's just a property of transfer
learning so this paper here says we
can't just use magnitude pruning when we
transfer learn because what will
basically that go by what will basically
say is them will assign the importance
based on based on the original neural
network tasks on the cat versus dog we
we will miss specify the importance of
the weights what we should do is
actually measure the importance with
respect to this task and how do they
achieve it so on a high level they're
basically saying okay if we start out
well this was fatal if we start out with
a point over here let's make that red
red I want to call it red
well it's blue now so if we are if we
start out with a point over here what we
should do what we should do is we should
observe how it moves during transfer
learning if it moves towards zero then
it's probably not that important for the
new task and if it moves to the to be
even larger then it's probably important
for that new task okay so that's that's
a high level now how do you measure how
it moves and what exact how exactly do
you do all of this during training such
that you don't make mistakes that's the
point of this paper they say we propose
movement pruning a simple deterministic
first order weight pruning method that
is more adaptive to pre trained model
fine-tuning we give mathematical
foundations to the method we compare it
to existing zero and first order pruning
methods okay so yeah we say so that's
basically on a high level that's that
now
how do they actually do it what they do
right here is the following they say
what we can define we can define each
each network layer basically as the
matrix multiplication by a weight now
you can express pretty much any neural
network as as such a multiplication with
a weight so you have X the in the signal
in each layer and you multiply that by
the weight matrix W now if you prune the
neural network you can see that right
here what you're saying is I basically
in here I have the matrix M which is a
mask so the mask is either 0 or 1
for if a weight is active or if the
weight is not active now this is not a
matrix multiply actually this is like a
hardier Mart product but you have this
mask matrix and what decides on this
mask this mask is decided as you can see
right here by this s so s s is a matrix
that for each entry and W it will decide
how important it is now in the classic
sense in the magnitude pruning you
already saw that this is just going to
be the absolute value of W IJ okay and
then the top V simply means that you
take the whoever or the most important
the most magnitude that those are going
to be one in the mask and everything
else is going to be zero in the mask
okay that's how this s is the W
determines the s and the s determines
the M okay so what you ultimately use is
the M right here but in now what we want
to do is we want to actually make the s
based on the movement and the movement
is not really a defined concept because
it goes over steps and so on so how do
you do the movement in in a kind of
dynamic way and this paper says you
should do it by gradient so you you
should observe the gradient of your loss
function with respect to this s matrix
to this importance matrix what does it
mean
so the
what does it mean it means let's
consider this quantity right here if s
is the importance of a particular
connection and if the gradient is large
that means this this connection moves a
lot it like the loss pulls it into a
particular direction okay so we're not
talking about yet which direction
actually the gradient has a sign it's
either positive or negative right so by
this quantity you can decide how much
does this new task want this particular
important score to move so if this is a
direct direct measure of how much
basically the loss function pulls on
that important score how much and it now
you can simply decide if and they have
these they have I think they have a
diagram yes
so but I don't like that let's go so we
have right here we have what's the value
of this gradient of L with respect to s
and here is W so if the gradient is
positive and W is already positive that
means the gradient goes into the
positive direction so you increase the
loss function in that let's put the
negative gradient here because you do
gradient descent right so um so if the
negative gradient is positive and the
weight is already positive in in this
case that means you're all the weight is
already high but now the loss function
wants to push it even higher so that
must be a very very important weight
right like it's like very good the same
goes if the gradient the negative
gradient is negative and the weight is
already negative the weight being
negative already means the weight you
know it has a negative sign and then the
gradient wants it to go
even more negative the the optimization
procedure says this thing should become
even more negative and also we say
that's probably a good way now the other
two cases means basically the way it's
already positive but the gradient wants
it to go negative which means it's
pulled towards zero
now it's entirely possible that it's
gonna cross zero and go like if you're
here going from over here gonna here
cross zero and become like super large
but that violates our basic assumptions
that the transfer learning doesn't move
the way it's too much right what you're
caring for is basically this local
neighborhood right here okay so you can
make the fair assumption that these
weights are not that important in the
case where the negative gradient goes
against the sign of the weight so this
this is of course discrete right now but
we can actually assign a number by how
large the gradient is and by how large
the weight already is and therefore we
can make a score so the important score
right here as you can see is the weight
multiplied by the gradient of the weight
and they can actually show
mathematically that if you do this over
multiple steps so you optimize while you
do this pruning and they do some sort of
a soft pruning so you can kind of
correct your mistakes later on I mean
they have hard and soft pruning but in
any case they can correct their mistakes
later on this will actually result in
these important scores being an
accumulation over the training over the
entire training of this quantity and
that's pretty cool because that means
eventually you sort of have a consistent
estimator of these important scores
across your training procedure okay
because the main fear was something like
this of course is that it's very brittle
and very much depends on the training
dynamics and who knows if in step one
something bad happens and so on but the
the math behind this here gives some
sort of more evidence that this it can
be like a self-correcting mechanism and
is actually not too dependent on the
particular training dynamic
so they do this experimental setup now
they have some they have some quirks
here actually let's first go to the the
actual different methods that compare
different methods right here or they say
okay there's magnitude pruning it's a
zero with order which basically just
means you just look at the weight
magnitude that that's it it's top V
which means you just pick the top
whatever and the objective is just the
loss and the scores are just the
absolute value we've seen this now
movement pruning on the other hand is
first order which means you look at the
movement in our case the gradient as you
can see here those are the importance
scores and you use this straight through
estimator which is basically just a way
of saying that even though you're
masking some things in the forward step
you shouldn't mask them in the in the
gradient backward step because you still
want gradient signal to reach so if you
have layers and you have a weight right
here at least that's how I understand it
I have not read that paper but if you
mask this one here you still want the
gradient to sort of flow backwards
because you still need the actual
importance scores for the weights that
here below connect to this weight I
think that's what is meant not entirely
sure in this though so but you can see
that the objective function is also the
actual loss function now this is
contrasted to a baseline called l0
regularization which is quite similar
but is also first order but has this
sort of regularizer right here and uses
the Gumbel softmax in order to determine
the scores and as you can see it also
has a different score function and it
has this um continuous hard concrete
importance in masking functions or a
masking function and they have a variant
of movement pruning that tends to
perform a little bit better which is
soft movement pruning where instead of
just going by the loss function
optimizing the loss function they
optimize the loss function plus
something now they have as you can see
here they have a threshold in masking
function and the threshold
is actually dynamic or it's determined
by the important scores and they have
done a regularizer that makes the
important scores sparse so instead of
saying we just want the top 5% of
weights they now just put a lot of mass
on this lambda right here which will
cause the s to be sparse and you know
they think if they are not happy with
how many weights they from they simply
increase or decrease this lambda such
that such that they get to their desired
sparsity of course you see there's the
direct trade-off with the loss function
right so the more you put weight on this
lambda the the less weight is you put
basically on the loss function itself so
you have to the trade-off here is very
explicit
whereas in basic movement pruning it's
just given by you masking away
completely the bottom one minus V of
percent of the weights but you see the
the score function is the same cup oh
well the score function here the score
function is the same okay now there
there are quite a number of tricks here
like there's this varsity scheduling
function and so on so as always in NLP
in with any big models there are a bunch
of bunch of engineering tricks that make
everything work better and you can never
exactly tell how much is due to that and
how much is due to the the actual
technique but if you know you can sort
of assess whether or not these um it's
done well and this here actually the
rationale makes sense and that's why I
tend to think that it is actually a
better method and the experiments are
very very convincing let's say
okay this is just a picture little
comparison where you can see movement
pruning ah sorry magnitude pruning all
it does is it looks at after you
fine-tune what are the weights and it
just cuts away everything in the middle
doesn't care about how the weights were
when before our movement pruning looks
at the combination of what were the
weights before and what are the weights
now and it cuts away everything where
the way it's moved towards zero which
are these quadrants right here and it
leaves in everything where it moved away
from zero or that's that's the the
ordering let's say that how much it
moved okay
experiments now as you might already
have figured out by now in the machine
learning and especially the NLP
community the methods presented always
outperform these previous methods in
this case it's pretty special so they
test this on this number of test squad
and NLM I and qqp and these are quite
hard tasks from an NLP perspective like
squatters question answering and analyze
like language inference this would be on
the I would I would guess these around
on the for an NLP system on the harder
side of tasks that's it's fairly cool
and as you can see here now just focus
on first of all focus on this ma P which
is the magnitude pruning so that's the
baseline if you will and the deep purple
on the smv P which which is the soft
movement pruning okay now you can also
focus on the MVP right here but they're
approximately the same now the are P P
you can maybe see in the graph is
performing fairly well even compared to
the full model and it's it's it's
another baseline basically but we just
want to compare those two and you can
see that in this regime that the
magnitude pruning outperforms the
movement pruning but however in this
regime the movement pruning is much
better and
that's the % where the % of remaining
weights is very very low so this is kind
of the extreme sparse case where you
only have 10% or you only have 3% of the
weights left and you can see that the
movement pruning is outperforming the
magnitude pruning by a lot okay now they
do discover that so this this happens in
all in all of these tasks as you can see
right here and they do they do discover
that if you then this still the model
further so in distillation this is yet
another technique that you can use to
boost the performance of the transfer
learned model so in distillation you
would not only train the model on you so
you have you now you have your this
model that you transfer learn and you
have the pruned version and in the print
version what you would do is you would
simply also train it on this data set
but what you can also do is you can
distill this model right here the one
that you train on the same task right
that's there's presumably better because
it still has all the weights okay you
can run a data point through both so the
same data point goes through this and
you get an output which are log 'its
which is like representing a
distribution saying yeah it's about this
high
now instead of assigning the hard labels
so here we also get the label right it's
a supervised learning task like 1 & 0
you also put the data point through this
model right here obtain whatever that
model would have said and let's say it's
about this and now presumably this model
is better already so you say well the
label here says that it's this class but
the model that's a really good says you
shouldn't be too sure about it so you
can sort of mix the two losses and this
this process of transferring the
knowledge of this model
to here is called distillation with the
lower model being the teacher model now
if you do distillation you can actually
improve your performance even more and
they show that in the experiments here
especially again in the low in the low
parameter regime but you can see for
example in squad here that the distilled
movement pruned method now catches up
with the magnitude pruned method in the
assigned the high in the not so sparse
regime okay and they analyzed these
weights and as you can see that expected
the magnitude pruned method it will
simply cut out anything right here
that's not not a surprise whereas the
movement pruned method it will leave a
lot of these weights alive so as you can
as you can see basically it's it's very
much the case since you can outperform
the red the yellow one can outperform
the red one it is almost warranted to
say that the this magnitude pruning
wasn't the best choice it's actually a
better choice to leave some of those
weights in it actually cut some of the
weights that are large out just based on
their movement now the V here in the
middle is of course due to the fact that
if a weight is here it was probably not
super important in the first place and
since since this thing removes anything
that moves towards zero any points
starting let's say around here moving
toward zero would end up here so all the
points that end up in this region
probably moved towards zero during
training and therefore are cut away so
there's there's not just like for there
to be points there would have been
points that started even more in the
middle and then moved out to here right
and there's just not as many so that's
why you have the V shape is very natural
to expect right here
so they they analyzed this then in terms
of the where the model cuts the weights
out now they experiment on a bird base
thing that which is a transformer with
12 layers and if you don't know what
bird is you can go look at my video on
bird but you can see that the magnitude
pruning will sort of cut all the weights
on the layers equally so it will sort of
go through the layers and take away
let's say 90% of each here you can see
10% of weights remaining whereas the
movement pruning especially the soft
movement pruning will actually make a
large difference it will remove much
much more of the later
layers weights and keep the lower layer
weights which I think if you do transfer
learning from these language models it
tends to be that the lower layers maybe
pick up if you if you think of a CNN the
lower layers might pick up you know on
these essential image features like
coroner's and so on and the higher
layers will pick up on the task specific
things now if you do like a big pre
training tasks you might have a lot of
information that you need there but then
if you distill it and transfer it down
to like a small set small tasks where
only a single thing is important like in
squad it's only important what's the
answer to the question then you can
probably remove a lot of that
superfluous information that was there
like high level features from the great
training task I mean that's my my guess
here but they also have explained that
so yeah that was this paper if you're
still here and you enjoyed it leave a
like tell me in the comments what you
think and I'll see you next time bye bye